LES VOGEL: And there we go.
PETE HOLLENHORST: We're
here at South by
Southwest in the hangout.
LES VOGEL: Yeah.
PETE HOLLENHORST: At the
Google Developer House.
LES VOGEL: At the Google
Developer House, where all the
excitement is happening.
There are LEGO building
contests, and we're giving
away Android tablets.
PETE HOLLENHORST: And
really cool tablets.
LES VOGEL: Real cool tablets.
So I'm here with Pete.
PETE HOLLENHORST: I'm Pete
Hollenhorst. I work as a
national product
trainer for LG.
ALAN QUEEN: And I'm
Alan Queen.
I'm the CTO of MOVL
from Atlanta.
HARPER LIEBLICH: And I'm
Harper Lieblich.
I'm the user experience designer
for iHeartRadio.
LES VOGEL: Cool.
So the questions I was asked to
ask, till we get some folks
popping in, is--
well, we know why you've
chosen to develop.
PETE HOLLENHORST: Yes.
LES VOGEL: So why did
you choose to
develop for Google TV?
ALAN QUEEN: I mean the main
reason is, is that we're able
to use everything we already
use every day as far as the
technologies go.
So if you're an Android
developer, it's all about
being able to take your existing
work and put it on
the TV experience.
So not only that, but as far as
HTML5 and web development,
comes right across with the
full Chrome browser.
So it's really easy to get your
ideas up and running on
Google TV, because it's things
you use every day.
LES VOGEL: OK, cool.
HARPER LIEBLICH: iHeartRadio
is a radio app, so it's all
about music.
It's all about being able
to listen to your
favorite radio station.
And for most people, the best
speakers in their house are
connected to their
televisions.
So it was a real great
opportunity for us to get our
app on people's televisions and
connected to those nice
big speakers that they've
got them plugged into.
And then we can also create a
neat living room experience
for people while they're
listening to their favorite
radio station, which is cool.
LES VOGEL: Cool.
Let's see.
I'm just going to--
PETE HOLLENHORST: We
traditionally supported Smart
TV for the last three years.
But one of the big things that
our customers came back, or
just the general consumer came
back and asked for something
that was faster.
They wanted something that
provided aggregate data, as
opposed to just randomly
searching across.
And Google has been that
partner for us.
It's really the fastest way to
go out and search for data and
take advantage of the current
content that you have, not add
to that additional content.
So from a hardware perspective,
Google is a
natural partnership, one
of the strongest
platforms that's out there.
LES VOGEL: And the LG TV is
really, really fast. And
Google TV.
PETE HOLLENHORST: Yeah, we
had talked about that.
So when we looked and did our
consumer test focus groups
across the board looking at
coming in on this platform,
one of the biggest things that
came across was the usability,
but more importantly, the
performance capability.
So when we selected a chipset,
we built our own chipset from
the ground up.
It's an LG Unitech L9 chipset.
And really what that does is
instead of just adding speed,
it complements exactly where
Google's heading.
And that's an app performance.
When we think TV, we're
thinking video-based
performance, we're thinking
graphic-based performance
that's out there.
So where it complements, I
think, is on that L9 chipset.
When I look at things like
Novellus developing, or even
iHeartRadio, just the transition
between screens,
hardware performance is very
important just for those fast
transitions or for faster
applications across the board.
We're looking forward to opening
up the capabilities of
what the software side can do.
With an accelerated speed you're
not only getting faster
search speeds, but you're also
getting better app development
that's supported.
LES VOGEL: And you're seeing
that in standard Google TV
apps, that they just run.
You download from Google Play,
and it just works.
PETE HOLLENHORST: That's
ultimately--
we can talk, we're going
to talk for a
while here at the hangout.
But at the end of the day,
that's what the average
consumer's looking for.
They want something that, I
think you guys would agree,
they just want something
that works.
LES VOGEL: Very cool.
Let's see, why don't I ask you,
you've got a lot of apps
that run on Google TV.
ALAN QUEEN: Sure.
LES VOGEL: Did you run into
any problems developing?
And how did you overcome them?
ALAN QUEEN: Well, when we first
started developing for
Google TV, it was last year.
It was before we were able to
create native Android apps.
And so we primarily focused on
developing for Google Chrome.
And so we have full screen
apps running
right in the browser.
And honestly, with that,
capabilities for us to be able
to develop locally on our
computers and have it run
almost identically on the TV,
was just great for us.
So there wasn't a whole
lot of issues there.
Obviously we've gone through a
couple of iterations of speed
and things like that, and just
working out some of the kinks
internally.
But for us it really hasn't
been a problem at all.
Now when we go to native
applications, one of the takes
that we're doing is still trying
to use HTML5 but inside
of Android applications, web
views and things like that, to
take advantage of what
we're already doing.
And so there's a couple issues
there that we've had, related
to making sure that the D-pad
still works in a normal
environment, getting into
things like that.
But we've been able to work all
that out, so we're able to
add just a little bit of native
Android code to make
our existing web apps work
inside of a native app.
LES VOGEL: Very cool.
ALAN QUEEN: Yep.
LES VOGEL: And iHeartRadio
is also a web app
that's coming out.
HARPER LIEBLICH: Yeah,
we developed the
whole thing in HTML5.
And we've made a lot of use of
transitions and animations.
And I think this platform
especially, when people sit
down on their mobile phone or
wherever else they use a
computer, it's not
always for fun.
But when you sit down in front
of your television, it's
almost always because you're
looking to have some fun,
looking for entertainment.
So we wanted to complement that
with some really neat--
you know, give it that whoosh,
give it that pizazz, and make
it really feel exciting
to use the app.
And so that's also been a
challenge to really make sure
that that feeling comes across
on these televisions with
regards to some of
the chipsets.
So it's also really neat to see
this running on the faster
televisions, because we can
really crank up that sexiness
of the app.
LES VOGEL: Yeah.
HARPER LIEBLICH: Which has
been a lot of fun.
LES VOGEL: And iHeartRadio
has got all kinds of cool
transitions, and it
really is good.
OK, I'm hoping to get a few
folks asking questions.
Ah, that's one of the
ones we get a lot.
The one question I have that's
been posted to the stream is,
when does Hulu Plus show up.
And that has nothing to do
with us, unfortunately.
I wish I could answer that.
It doesn't.
Any of you have questions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LES VOGEL: We're doing a live
hangout out here at South by
Southwest. Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Can everyone hear me OK?
LES VOGEL: Oh yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you, guys.
I am really happy to be here.
I'm a big fan of Google TV,
and especially what
you guys are doing.
So thank you.
I was wondering, when you
leverage using television as
that larger medium as a screen,
as far as resolution,
what are some of the benefits
that most consumers can really
get or extract value from by
having a much larger screen
than a computer screen
has in the past?
LES VOGEL: Well, I'll start, but
one of the things that you
think about for a television is
it's actually not larger.
For the 10-foot experience, if
you hold a tablet up close and
then look up at your TV, the
TV actually looks smaller.
And so the information density
is not as great.
So you need to think about TVs
differently than you do a
computer or a tablet, and not
put as much information.
Put bigger things up there.
Make it more fun but more
focused in a sense.
HARPER LIEBLICH: I think the
biggest advantage of this form
factor is it's a
social screen.
It's not a bunch of people
crowding around a computer.
It's not even a cell phone,
which is very personal.
This is about a bunch of
people sitting down and
watching something or
using something.
So the apps that really take
advantage of that-- and you
can speak to this-- are the
ones that are really gonna
take advantage of that
social experience.
LES VOGEL: Yeah.
ALAN QUEEN: Yeah, definitely.
I think that when we
use our mobile
devices, that's a very--
like you said, it's a
personal experience.
It's my little view
into the world.
But the TV is something that's
common to everyone in the
house most of the time, you
know, when you have it above
your fireplace or things
like that.
So it's a very social
experience, where everyone's
in the living room
watching it.
So being able to take advantage
of not just a larger
screen, but that social nature
is what we're all about.
Creating multi-screen
applications for multiple
people to use at the same time,
all controlled from
their mobile devices.
So we really think that's a very
exciting opportunity for
Smart TV apps.
Everyone's already in their
living room using these
devices while they watch TV,
so we're trying to take
advantage of that, and let
people actually be social
around the TV, rather than just
looking at their phone
while they're watching TV
and ignoring each other.
So anyway, that's just another
aspect that we think is really
great about bringing
applications to the TV.
Of course, obviously TV is a
lean back, veg-out experience,
traditionally.
But there's a lot of interesting
things you can do
once you get some interactivity
going with all
the people in the house all
gathered around the TV.
PETE HOLLENHORST: I'm actually
going to take a
different take on it.
I think that by going to a
TV aspect, you open the
demographic up.
If you watch who's interacting,
not just at South
by Southwest, but just in the
general public, it's a very
dedicated sect of people.
I mean, it's a wider
variation.
But going to a TV platform opens
that up to people that
traditionally wouldn't get
involved in this content area.
I've got a 90-year-old
grandfather that probably
wouldn't have, and isn't.
He's got an iPhone and he thinks
it's cool because he
can FaceTime, but
that's about it.
For him, that's all that
experience is.
When I showed him the
capabilities of Thuuz, or when
I show him the capabilities
of iHeartRadio, again, it
personalizes that experience.
He never would've gotten that
through any smartphone or
tablet application if it hadn't
been on a TV. There's
something intrinsically
about TV that makes
it familiar to everybody.
From a very early age we were
taught that it's OK to be in
that TV experience, and
to promote that social
capability.
So it's just that spoonful of
sugar, if you will, to help
the medicine go down.
LES VOGEL: Yeah, TV is a very
relaxing, fun, social
experience.
And so you're thinking about
everything differently.
PETE HOLLENHORST: That's
a good question.
LES VOGEL: Yeah, it is.
PETE HOLLENHORST: It's a
really good question.
I'm sure there's something else,
though, that somebody
else has got.
LES VOGEL: Anyone have
any other questions?
OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the
developers talk about their
favorite parts of
their own app?
What they think is [INAUDIBLE]
the best features [INAUDIBLE]?
LES VOGEL: Cool.
HARPER LIEBLICH: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Better repeat
the question.
LES VOGEL: Yeah, we were asked
for each developer to talk
about what part of their apps
highlights the Google TV
experience and what is really
exciting about their apps.
HARPER LIEBLICH: Yeah.
I think, like Les said earlier,
because you can only
fit so much information on the
screen at a time, you have to
really think clearly about what
it is that's the core of
your app and why people want to
use it, and remove all of
the extra bells and whistles
so that you've really got a
clean, easy-to-use experience.
And it's that focus that for
us was sort of refreshing.
It allowed us to strip away all
of the extraneous things
that we've got going on on our
other platforms, and just
focus on that core
radio-listening experience.
So that's one of my favorite
things about it.
And then the other was the
freedom to really play with
the visual style and to make
it feel open and inviting.
Because it's in somebody's
living room, we want to make
sure that they feel comfortable
as soon as they go
into that app.
And I love that I feel like
we've been able to make
something that draws you in
instead of making you feel
overwhelmed by information
on your screen.
ALAN QUEEN: I don't want
to turn this into a UX
discussion, but it brought up
an interesting thing that I
always like when people say, an
app is not done until you
can't take anything else away.
So that's very important for
TV, strip out everything.
It's not done when you can't
add anything else to it.
But what MOVL does is really
take advantage of the TV and
the second screen experience.
So we're all about everybody
around the living room using
their mobile devices, their
tablets, to interact together
in a social experience where
the TV is the anchor point,
whether that's in a living room
at home, or it might be
in a bar in a restaurant, that
people can actually use this
TV and the mobile devices in a
really social way to have a
lot of fun, entertainment-based
applications.
So for us, that's the best thing
about developing for TV,
is being able to use this thing
to actually do all of
your text input, your searching,
your finding all
your content, and using the TV
to really act as the anchor
point in the display area
for the device.
And obviously for Google
TV, we're able to
do that very easily.
So we've been really happy
with the experience.
LES VOGEL: Oh, cool.
So Cliff writes in, asks about
two things about the LG.
One is, do you support
the NTFS file system?
PETE HOLLENHORST: Yeah.
LES VOGEL: And then the second
one is, do you have any good
video chat apps being planned,
and supporting
a camera for this?
I don't know you've announced
anything, but--
PETE HOLLENHORST: No.
So on NTFS, not at this point
that we're going to discuss.
I can tease the video aspects.
If you've taken a look at some
of the specs that got leaked
or talked about from CES,
or even here at South by
Southwest, we talked about
the USB inputs.
And we've always natively
supported cameras with that,
so there is a lot that's being
planned, nothing that we're
announcing here at South
by Southwest.
What I was going to say is just
my favorite part of--
LES VOGEL: OK, sorry.
PETE HOLLENHORST: --where that
goes into is, coming into this
platform, we tried to attack it
from three dedicated points
in terms of usability.
And that's where that magic
motion came into play, with a
very easy-to-use remote control,
coming in and talking
about just the overall
performance, and not only a
good chipset, but a native UI
that worked well and then in
terms of content.
But all three of those feed back
into, what is that total
user experience for it?
So tying in our 3D, tying in
Google TV, tying in all of
that, we want to make sure that
people are able to interact.
So we're not announcing
anything, but I will point out
again that we've got two USBs.
Most of the time you
only need one.
And we do have a USB camera
that's available.
So you can draw your
own conclusions.
LES VOGEL: OK.
And then there's another
question from
Russia, from Alexander.
PETE HOLLENHORST: Hello,
Alexander.
LES VOGEL: And he asks, what
media formats and containers
will LG TV support?
Will MPEG-2 be supported?
And will DTS be supported?
PETE HOLLENHORST: So yeah, we're
actually that format
king across the board.
In fact, there's very
few formats that we
don't play nice with.
But for Alexander that's out
there, MPEG-2 is definitely
something we're going
to support.
Plex is a great way to
bring that back in.
Any of your native content, if
Plex supports it, we're going
to be able to play that back
on our TVs across.
I'm sure there's some
good questions,
though, coming through.
Actually, I was going to
ask about iHeartRadio.
Where is the evolution
then coming from?
From a radio standpoint on TV,
where's the user impact?
Why would I first
be interested?
And what's the nice to know, not
the need to know, but what
the nice to know feature about
iHeartRadio that you're
anticipating?
HARPER LIEBLICH: In terms of
what's coming up, or what's on
there right now?
Well, one of the things that
we're trying to do is,
obviously, we interview
lots of artists
and bands and musicians.
We've got great photos and
videos and articles about
them, so that's one thing we're
talking about bringing
into the experience across all
of our different platforms.
But I think especially the video
aspect of that works
great on the television.
And then the other is just
enhancing that social
experience so that people feel
like they're sharing with each
other, because radio is
such a social medium.
There's always people
calling in.
There's always people talking
to each other, whether it's
DJs and hosts.
And so we want to really try
to tie that in and make it
feel even more social when it's
in people's living rooms.
LES VOGEL: One thing I didn't
find out when I first saw
iHeartRadio a couple weeks ago
was, is it just Clear Channel
radio stations or is it
a broad selection?
HARPER LIEBLICH: Up until
recently it was just Clear
Channel radio stations.
And that's 800 radio stations
across the country.
But we're now starting to
bring in other stations.
And that's including
Univision.
We've got a couple of public
radio stations coming in,
including WNYC in New York.
And we're now, for the first
time, starting to talk about
bringing in college
radio stations.
LES VOGEL: Oh, very cool.
HARPER LIEBLICH: So you'll be
able to listen to a whole
gamut of different
terrestrial-type radio stations.
LES VOGEL: So it's a
good eclectic set?
HARPER LIEBLICH: Yeah.
I think there's something
in there for everybody.
LES VOGEL: Let's see.
Anyone else in the room
have another question?
AUDIENCE: I do.
LES VOGEL: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: MOVL, can you talk
about building from the living
room, and then also just the
way you're thinking about
Google TV and bringing it to,
like, a bar or [INAUDIBLE]?
ALAN QUEEN: Sure.
So the question is about how
MOVL is transforming our
living room games into more
public space applications for
bars and restaurants
and other things.
So when we started all this,
we always thought that it
would be great to take that
multi-screen experience from
the living room to bars
and restaurants.
Any bar you go to, I mean if you
guys are going up and down
Sixth Street, just count the
number of TVs that are in all
those bars.
So we see those there and how
many people see those every
single day and every
single night.
And imagine if all those
have Google TV on it.
What would you do with it?
So the way we approached it
is, we want to have apps
running on the TV, but then have
everyone else pull out
their mobile device and
be able to play along.
So it's just as easy as
downloading an app.
And in a bar you might play
trivia, you might play poker.
So that's what we're doing.
We actually have a new product
coming out called The
Neighborhood, which is going
to be launching in several
bars and restaurants
in the Chicago
area in a couple weeks.
And we're hoping to launch that
in many more across the
country over this year.
But it will allow you
to do just that.
So you'll be able to walk into
the bar and actually compete
with other people.
And it's a really social
experience because the TV on
the wall functions as where
everyone discovers it and
plays along.
But they're also connected
to each other.
So private messaging, chatting,
you can imagine all
the different things that are
gonna happen in a bar setting
or a cafe setting.
It's not just for bars.
It's actually for retail, bars,
cafes, coffee shops,
that kind of a thing.
LES VOGEL: And that can work
with anyone's mobile phone.
Do they download your app or
just go to the website?
ALAN QUEEN: So we're going to
be doing both versions.
So you can actually just go to
a URL on your phone, and
you'll be able to play along.
And so all the connection
stuff happens via HTML5,
WebSockets, that kind
of a thing.
So any HTML5-enabled browser
for mobile phones
will work just fine.
And then we'll also have a
downloadable version, so you
can get to it a little
faster as well.
LES VOGEL: And Summer asks, how
are mobile devices able to
interact with the Google TV?
I'm assuming she's asking
about the SDK.
ALAN QUEEN: Yeah, so we actually
have a platform and
an SDK, a set of APIs that
anyone can use to create
multi-screen applications
for Smart TVs. I
know that's a mouthful.
But if you go to
connect.movl.com, all you have
to do is sign up and you can
download APIs for iOS,
Android, JavaScript,
and even Flash.
And everything is designed from
the ground up around the
Smart TV experience.
You create an app on the TV.
We call that the host
application.
And then you create an app for
your mobile device that acts
as the companion application.
We call that the controller
application.
So once all the devices are
connected, you can route
messages between them and it
doesn't have to be over the
same local Wi-Fi network.
It actually works through
the cloud as well.
So you can have TV-to-TV play,
so social in the living room,
and social across the net,
multi-user, multi-user gaming,
things like that.
PETE HOLLENHORST: I--
ALAN QUEEN: What?
Oh, oh thank you so much.
We got a fan, we got a fan.
LES VOGEL: Yeah.
And so the camera's not
on it, but your app
over there has a code.
They just enter that code and
they're immediately synced.
ALAN QUEEN: Yeah, it's
really simple.
So on the TV, every TV has a
special pairing code to it,
and you just enter
it one time.
Enter the code once.
It's a five-digit code.
And then you're connected
to that television.
LES VOGEL: OK.
ALAN QUEEN: And then that
television is also connected
to other televisions and
[INAUDIBLE] down the line.
And then whatever activity is
happening on that TV at that
moment, you also see the
companion interface show up on
your mobile device
at the same time.
LES VOGEL: Very cool.
ALAN QUEEN: And then we're going
to extend that too, so
that if you walk into a bar,
it'll be location aware.
So we'll be able to connect
you even easier
than entering a code.
LES VOGEL: Oh, that's
a great idea.
[PHONE RINGS]
ALAN QUEEN: Yeah.
Nothing like getting
a live phone call.
Get them-- there.
PETE HOLLENHORST: Yeah,
I'm that guy.
I'm sure it's somebody calling
in with a question.
ALAN QUEEN: Yes, exactly.
PETE HOLLENHORST: It's
not a call-in show.
LES VOGEL: OK, so do we
have other questions?
AUDIENCE: Before you wrap up,
can each one of you give a
one-sentence tip?
It has to be different
from each one of you.
Each one of you has to give a
different tip for making a
great app or a TV experience.
PETE HOLLENHORST: OK.
I know.
[INAUDIBLE] that way.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HARPER LIEBLICH: I would say
it's really important to make
sure that the user always knows
where their focus is.
This is a different--
ALAN QUEEN: From a developer
point of view, I would say,
get a TV and test on your TV.
Don't rely on anything else.
Yes, you can do the custom
builds for the Linux boxes for
Google TV, but get a TV and
get people using it.
Obviously, that goes with any
application, but this is
definitely for TV.
PETE HOLLENHORST: Mine is just,
if we're developing key
structure, just what may be
intuitive for you or what you
think works well for you, please
test it amongst as many
people as you can find.
In fact, approach random
strangers.
I've seen a ton of different
apps where
it's just not intuitive.
And if it's not intuitive,
it's an app
that doesn't get used.
That's my biggest request if
you're watching right now.
LES VOGEL: And the number one
feature that we test for that
prevents apps from getting
featured that play audio is
respecting and requesting
audio focus.
We reject apps because
of that.
When you're in the living room,
play well with others.
And that's a real key thing.
And [INAUDIBLE]
just Google Android
audio [INAUDIBLE].
It's usually a line before you
start playing, a line after,
and about four or five lines
of code [INAUDIBLE] one man
for [INAUDIBLE]
recognizing.
And now we're getting an
incoming broadcast, maybe.
OK, it's not happening.
All right, thank you very
much for coming.
We're live from South by
Southwest in Austin.
Aloha.
[APPLAUSE]